EXPLOSIVE SCIENCE NEWS!
ORGASMS ARE GOOD FOR YOU!
I know, it's really exciting, but there's
a rub to this study.
Hey gang, thanks for watching DNews I'm Trace!
Sex and alcohol go together like french fries
and mayo.
Depending on who you are, you don't necessarily
WANT them together, but it totally happens.
Both alcohol and sex make people happy, and
both make people feel closer to others, but
one of them is lying...
Both alcohol and sex help people talk to each
other.
Sometimes, a stiff drink makes it easier to
face a tough discussion, and sometimes sex
makes that discussion seem less insurmountable.
A new study in Communication Monographs examined
how alcohol and orgasms encourage people to
talk and share intimate details about themselves.
It comes down to the chemicals and what they
do to the brain.
Orgasms are gooooood.
They are, just.
Yes.
Orgasm releases chemicals like oxytocin, human
growth hormone, serotonin, dopamine, vasopressin,
norepinephrine and others.
These chemicals help you look younger, focus,
and live longer, they boost your immune system,
help you bond with your partner and, of course,
make you feel good.
When you're drunk, your brain releases endorphins
and dopamine which also make you feel good
-- same as an orgasm -- but, because alcohol
is a depressant, it doesn't make you feel
good in the long run.
As you drink, alcohol causes the suppression
of the natural neuro-excitatory chemical glutamate
and boosts gamma-Aminobutyric acid or GABA
which is like Xanax or Valium and sedates
the brain.
Basically, alcohol is a depressant that makes
you feel good... at first.
After a little while, the depressants win
out and your brain is left sad and inhibited.
After sex is when partners are most likely
to talk intimately and bond.
However, these two paths lead to VERY different
results.
Orgasm's BFF oxytocin, is called the "love
hormone" or the "trust hormone," and, according
to the new research, the pillowtalk occurring
after an orgasm is positive and causes bonding.
Sharing those intimate details will maintain
a shallow release of hormones too, keeping
you both feeling good and increasing trust
and bonding even more!
Add in some alcohol though, and you're in
for a strange cocktail of brain chemicals.
When alcohol and orgasms cross paths, people
still feel that need to share intimate stories
about their lives, but instead of being positive,
their intimate details consist of less important
information, and are less positive.
On top of that, "people who drink more alcohol,"
said the study's co-author, "perceive fewer
benefits to disclosing information to their
partners."
And if a drunk person fails to have an orgasm,
the negative feelings are compounded!
At the end of the day, drunk sex can be fun
-- wear a condom -- but though the stimulants
of orgasm feel as though they're counteracting
the depressants of alcohol, they're not.
Partners who want to truly bond with their
partners, science says, should have sober
pillowtalk.
It's the best.
What do you think of this study?
Share your feelings on intimate communication
in the comments, and be sure you subscribe
for more DNews -- and if you're jonesin' for
more daily news check out TestTube.
This week we talked about military advisors
and what they ACTUALLY do, the problems with
child immigration, the differences between
Sunni and Shia Muslims and tons of other super
interesting deep looks into the news of the
day.
I think this might be one of my new favorite
shows!
Click here to subscribe, and check out TestTube
every day, just like DNews.